I guess just to start off with writing
together and being husband and wife how
does that work without you both killing
one another
well I cook for her oh I can always
steer her attention away from the
argument by saying well what do you want
for dinner tonight what do you prefer
and you name it you know I make
everything I make eventually turns into
a burrito but it starts out with good
intentions oh yeah oh yeah and we have
us we have a system that works really
well for us because we've decided we
decide at the beginning who owns this
project in essence who has the veto over
the other person because sometimes
writers cannot agree and they can say we
disagree but then ultimately there has
to be a decide what were the big
disagreements on this movie so much it
really comes down to that when you're
adapting a book things have to go okay
so it's like oh but we need that oh and
it's like yes no it's great in the book
it's great but has to go something has
to go so that it tends to come down to
that what do you what do you cut out
what how do you figure out what can go
in yeah cut out all the helicopter
crashes machine gun fire so much of that
superheroes flying around in capes all
that we cut and it's amazing it's about
distilling it down to its essence so you
know there might be sort of repeated
beats I know I make mistakes in my life
and then I make the same mistake again
that happens in a book you don't really
get to do that in a movie as much you
have to move forward
having done the process for the first
film do you learn from that or do you I
hope so
yeah the we've been we wrote together a
lot before we got anything made and so
we had gotten into a really good rhythm
but it's absolutely true that there's a
complete difference between writing a
studio movie and then seeing it shot as
opposed to writing a studio movie that
they don't make completely different you
know on the set well you know pitch
things over I mean it's a it's a group
process oh how does the movie change
onset in the moment oh wait the actors
feel like they need an adjustment or
something doesn't taste right in their
mouth you're like that's and that's how
it should be how does knowing the PG
rating affect your sort of writing
process are there things that are too
dark
oh no if you read a dog's purpose you
read a dog's journey you realize that
when I write a book I'm not putting a
lot of really adult themes in there
there's certainly not adult scenes
mm-hmm especially what it's told from
the standpoint of a dog who probably
could watch something we'd consider to
be carnal and not know what's going on
so the way it's described in the book is
very you not an oculus and that's fine
it's a childlike voice of a dog yeah
well I mean the movie does deal with
reincarnation which is not something
that is typically sort of discussed in
sort of America how did you sort of sky
settle on that how did that come about I
talk yeah yeah I just wanted to tell her
a story to convince her to get another
dog she told me she doesn't want one oh
no we got to get another dog so I told
her a story that convinced her that her
dog who died was out there looking for
in the in the form of pure love if she
just knew where to find but if you think
about it we don't know and there's no
way for us to know Tucker could be
reincarnated he could have been my old
dog we don't know he can't tell me so
you you know it could be true I mean
there are serious things in this movie
made deals with mortality and that sort
of stuff like what do you hope that
family sort of get out of it well I
think that one of the greatest things
about a dog's purpose a dog's journey is
that the dog is seeing everything
through its own innocent loving eyes and
therefore none of these deep traumatic
things that happen to people really
affect a dog that much the dog rolls
with the punches dogs are so good at
accepting whatever's going on